z 17 vous allez partir tranquillement
vous partez en groupe de six vous avez
déjà fait les groupes
donc vous avez domaine de 10 tentation 1
et puis voilà et bien je vous souhaite
une bonne marche et c'est parti pour 12
km de marche pas trop de 6 à la
découverte de ces paysages du sancerrois
ou le printemps et les gens qui montrent
le bout de leur nez sont une quarantaine
de coureurs et de marcheurs
il respire et transpire de nouveau grâce
à ce rendez-vous berisha on est en plein
air donc avec le respect des gestes
barrières n'y a pas de raison face mac
donc faut faire le faire parce qu'on en
a besoin je pense depuis un an où on ne
peut pas trop faire ce qu'on a envie
faut le faire tout en respectant bien
sûr les conditions parce qu'il faut faut
respecter un peu cette distanciation
tout ça pour qu'on puisse se sortir de
cette crise en cessant sienne le bonheur
de se retrouver en pleine nature de
profiter encore tu en arrives ici la vie
me soleil les copains la convivialité le
partage c'est c'est vivre profiter une
crise sanitaire qui pose problème aussi
au club
quand on est responsable d'un club la
situation est bien sûr très difficile
actuellement pour essayer de motiver nos
athlètes de ne serait-ce que pour les
conserver déjà puisque courir la fin ne
plus pouvoir s'entraîner à partir de 18
heures ça pose beaucoup de problèmes
pour des raisons professionnelles
familiales diverses que les deux
itinéraires d'aujourd'hui 12 et 16 km
sont des remises en forme qui permettent
de pallier toutes ces annulations de
courses en toute sécurité
le trouver
moyen de partager notre passion et de
fédérer et de trouver aussi que avec
avec tout ça on peut respecter les
règles sanitaires
moi je prend le nom de tout le monde
depuis loin du 1 et depuis ce jour là
j'ai jamais eu aucun contact des
coureurs pas si fou que ça même si
certains sont inscrits à la diagonale en
octobre
[Musique]